mal angenommen jetzt dichter ich bin 17
und ich würde mit einer 27 jährigen oder
so ausgehen jetzt mal nur als beispiele
dann wird jeder direkt herkommen war bei
dir läuft heftigst respekt du bist geil
und so weiter aber wenn ein mädchen das
option ist mit einem 27-jährigen ausgeht
dann comdirect als pädophil
aber er okay ist halt warten nachteil
das nachteil
stimmt es mir gar nicht aufgefallen
hatte kommt man hier jungs aber auch
vorteile
leute was geht ab willkommen zu einem
neuen video und zwar hab ich mir für
heute überlegt ich habe schon mal vor
drei vier monaten oder so dieses
vorteile jeder frau video gemacht und ja
das ist schon ziemlich gut bei euch
angekommen und deswegen gibt halt
einfach den zweiten teil davon
allerdings muss ich dazu sagen das ist
jetzt nicht so generell auf vorteil
jeder frau bezogen sondern er so auf
vorteile des mädchens jedes teenager
mädchens oder so halt keine ahnung
ebenso zwischen 12 und 18
irgendwie sowas halt und ja ich wünsche
euch viel spaß weise gefällt dass auf
jeden fall noch nach oben der abonniere
nicht vergessen und jetzt viel spaß mit
dem video
ich würde sagen logischerweise mit punkt
eins an und zwar ist es ja so dass
mädchen halt mädchen erwarten immer dass
sie angeschrieben werden und teil nicht
die jungs dass sie angeschrieben
aufwendig zwar cool fände wenn mädchen
obwohl nicht spaß aber halt ihr wisst
bestimmt was ich meine also mädchen
gehen immer davon aus dass sie
angeschrieben werden und dass der inhalt
auf alles zu kommt auf keine ahnung
erstes treffen oder so eine kalt und ja
das finde ich ein blöd warum machen wir
das machen müssen warum nicht mädchen
und das ist also ein vorteil von euch ne
und dann geht es auch schon weiter mit
punkt 2 und zwar ist es bei mir auch
ziemlich oft so ich denke ich könnte mal
wieder ein foto für in sorge machen oder
halten snap sind mit snapshot was auch
immer und dann holt man so das handy
roßkopf wir rein und denkt sich ein see
scheiße aus nah und bei mädchen ist es
so wenn ich scheiße aus oder wenn sie
selber denken ich sehe euch voll scheiße
aus
und er ihre haare nehmen die das gesicht
legen und dann geht das auch klar aber
ich kann das halt nicht
und glaub ich will dass ich meine haare
zerstören aber ist also das finde ich
blöd ich weiß was ich machen soll damit
ich dann besser aus hier das ist einfach
manchmal so es gibt tage an denen sich
einer scheißhaus wenn ich in die handy
kamera gucken und es gibt aber auch tage
an denen sich einfach spaß
ich sage besser nichts werden sollte bei
dem nächsten punkte muss ich schon
ziemlich aufpassen was ich sage aber es
kommt für mich halt manchmal so rüber
und zwar so noten technisch jetzt nicht
unbedingt die schriftliche note in der
schule sondern so die mündliche note in
der schule da werden doch mädchen ab und
suchen nicht bei lehrern aber bei dem
ein oder anderen ein bisschen ein ganz
kleines bisschen bevor zu ja also das
kommt für mich einfach drüber ich weiß
ich wie ihr das denkt ihr könnt gerne
dazu ein kommentar in die kommentare
schreiben aber ja irgendwie manchmal
denke ich mir das ist voll und verrat
aber na ja und da kommt auch schon zu
pop nummer vier und zwar wenn man jetzt
nicht gerade einen nebenjob besitzt oder
so 20.000 euro wie ich im monate youtube
verdient kann es schon mal sein dass in
einer beziehung das portemonnaie vom
jungen leer ist und vom mädchen halt
immer voll weil der junge gibt dem
mädchen her immer meistens aus und ein
mädchen nicht dem jungen gehört sich
auch so ich will ja auch nicht sehen
sagen aber das ist ja ein vorteil von
euch und das mit geldprämien nimmt er
sich zu ernst
der nächste punkt er ist eigentlich für
uns alle so relativ normal das ist
einfach so ne aber wenn man es war ein
bisschen hinterfragt dann denkt man auch
so wieso ist das würde sich mein mädchen
die können von make up bis aila bis was
weiß ich ich kann mich damit jetzt nicht
so wirklich aus alles in ihr gesicht
klatschen und wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel hier stehen würde und ich würde
sagen ja dass hier sieht doof aus und
dann hier so ein bisschen make-up nehmen
würden das stelle einfach vor das ist
jetzt wirklich hier im video wie viele
von euch den spaß macht dass sich aber
wie viele von euch werden in die
kommentare schreiben
ist er schwul keinen sinn eigentlich
keinen sinn oder warum ist das so
verstehe ich nicht aber naja hier dieses
eklige und dann jetzt zum letzten punkt
wenn man sich als mädchen so wirklich
normal verhält sich normal ansieht ich
habe noch nie mädchen gesehen was nicht
in club reinkommen ist wenn ich irgendwo
hingehe abends und dann stehen da vor
jungs sie kommen einfach nicht rein
so aber das sind nur
es sind keine mädchen finde ich unfair
warum paarung ist das wetter so und
jetzt halten vorträge ja heute falls
euch das video gefallen dass auf jeden
fall dort nach oben da abonnieren ich
vergessen wenn ihr nichts mehr verpassen
wollte und hier ist jetzt noch mal ins
allgemeine bild checkt auf jeden fall
machen ich heiß auf twitter genauso
facebook auf und dann würde ich sagen
hier auf der linken seite geht weiter am
netz wieder das war mit jannik ostern
sommer sind so ein spiel gemacht und auf
der anderen seite mit dem ersten teil
von vorteile jedes mädchens jeder frau
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
sonntag von drei hatte